concept of being a slave to Allah you
know Allah ultimately speaks about
people as being enslaved to multiple
things many people are enslaved to their
desires some people aren't sleep to
their difficulties they can't see beyond
their difficulty in fact anything that
they've done worship is with one sole
intention of escaping a difficulty so
Allah mentions there are some people
that worship Allah on an edge on a cliff
for their worship of Allah is insincere
because if good is coming to them then
they stay on but if hardship comes to
them they jump off of the cliff they
leave their creator their worship of
Allah was either insincere or
inconsequential it wasn't true servitude
it wasn't true slavery to Allah there
are people that are enslaved to their
friends the opinions of people some
people are enslaved by their fears and
Islam kind of comes with this full
package of Liberation Allah has sent us
to liberate people from being slaves to
other slaves to being slaves of the Lord
of all slaves